Hillary Swank won Fame and acclaim for
her oscar-winning performance in 1999's
Boys Don't Cry and did it all over again
just five years later in Million Dollar
Baby then Hollywood suddenly stopped
talking about her why did she go from in
demand to out of the spotlight here are
a few theories
she won two Oscars too quickly
they say that winning an Oscar can be a
curse but winning two in the span of
five years that's a whole other story
Swang faced backlash in Hollywood after
she won her second Best Actress Oscar in
2005 for the Clint Eastwood boxing drama
Million Dollar Baby suddenly the actress
had gone from starring in 90210 to
joining the ranks of fable two-time
winners like Betty Davis and Vivian Lee
and she beat out deserving actresses
like the long-suffering Annette Benning
who still has never won an Oscar shut up
beyond the politics of who deserved what
Swank was inevitably set up for failure
by the academy by age 30 she had far
exceeded expectations at that point
there was no place to go but down
she got lucky
the strange thing about swing's two
Oscar wins is that they were both
lightning at a bottle moments in her
career she certainly gave excellent
performances and both boys don't cry and
Million Dollar Baby nobody's going to
look back and say to themselves wait she
won an Oscar for that we're looking at
you Marissa Tomei I'm watching you go
down in flames and you're bringing me
with you and I can't do anything about
it the problem is outside of those two
movies Swank has never done anything
that warranted that level of a claim
before Boys Don't Cry she was only
really known for movies like The Next
Karate Kid and getting fired from 90210
and afterwards she continued to star in
mediocre projects like Iron Jawed Angels
and the affair of the necklace
so was she great or did she just happen
to appear in great movies
lousy post Oscar projects Swank had a
difficult time finding success after a
Million Dollar Baby was released in
2004. she alternated wildly between
starring and Prestige movies that were
too mediocre for Oscar consideration and
mainstream flicks that seem more geared
towards making money than satisfying
critics one of her roughest patches came
in 2009 when she starred in the Amelia
Earhart biopic Emilia which was in every
sense of the word a disaster reviews
were terrible at earned a 20 score on
Rotten Tomatoes and box office returns
were even worse the film grossed just
14.2 million dollars against a reported
40 million dollar budget and Swank's
days of Oscar Glory started to feel like
a thing of the past not that it bothers
her she told the independent that you're
an artist and you're putting yourself
out there and you take that leap and
sometimes you fly and sometimes you fall
she has other interests part of the
reason Swank hasn't been making as many
great films is because she's devoting
her time to helping needy kids and
animals with her non-profit charity it's
called the hillaroo foundation and
animals who have been abandoned and
children who've been given up on
together to help heal each other through
rescue Rehabilitation and responsibility
training it's all part of her new focus
on living every moment of her life to
the fullest you know you just never know
what's going to happen tomorrow and you
have to really be in the moment and
be present
he's been caring for her dad
Swank's absent from the spotlight has
also had to do with family concerns
Beyond her own control in 2015 the
actress reveals the Huffington Post that
she had recently put her career in the
back burner in order to take care of her
ailing father who had just had a lung
transplant it's a certain amount of time
and in a lifespan it's a blink of an eye
and I wouldn't change it for the world I
mean there's there's been job
opportunities that I've passed on things
that I said I can't but I mean really
what we're here for is our family right
luckily her father is on the mend giving
Swank a chance to give back on the movie
business and hopefully regain her role
as one of Hollywood's top actresses does
she have a future on TV
soon swipe will test her luck on
television again with the new stars
drama the one percent the premiere date
is still up in the air but it already
boasts a slew of high profile names
including Ed Helms Ed Harris and
oscar-winning director Alejandro G and
yaritu who created and co-wrought the
project so don't worry too much about
Swank her Oscar days may or may not be
behind her but her Emmy days could just
be starting thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos at the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know what kinds of roles you think
Hollywood should find for Hilary Swank